We have negative 5x cubed times y squared, squared. So I should write this
twice. Now that I have a product of factors, I can regroup the basis that are
alike. So I have two negative 5, two x cubes, and two y squared's multiplied
together. That would have been the same if I would just distributed the square
to each of the terms. I would have had two negative 5, two x cubes, and two y
squared. Now that I'm here, I can multiply my numbers together, and my bases
together. Negative 5 times negative 5 is positive 25 times 2 is 50. For the base
of x, I simply add the exponents together, 3 plus 3 makes 6 and 7 makes 13. The
y's are a little bit easier, so I just have y to the 4th. All together I have 50
times x to the 13th times x to the 4th. If you reasoned your way somewhat
through that or got any of these exponents right, great job. If you got this
right on your first try, that's even more impressive, great work.